DON'T EVEN SEEM TO NOTICE OR
CARE.
WE HAVE AN INVESTIGATIVE REPORT
WITH SARA CARTER.
FIRST, BIG NEWS ABOUT JOE
BIDEN'S GARAGE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW BY NOW THIS IS
WHERE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE
DISCOVERED.
DISCOVERED IN FOUR PLACES, ONE
OF THE FOUR PLACES.
JUST LAYING AROUND NEAR BIDEN'S
CORVETTE RIGHT THERE.
APPARENTLY THEY HAVE BEEN THERE
FOR YEARS BUT JOE ISN'T WORRIED
AT ALL.
DOESN'T THINK IT'S A BIG DEAL AT
ALL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'RE FULLY COOPERATING AND
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING
THIS RESOLVED QUICKLY.
I THINK YOU'LL FIND THERE IS
NOTHING THERE.
I HAVE NO REGRETS.
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING WHAT THE
LAWYERS HAVE TOLD ME THEY WANT
ME TO DO.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING.
NO THERE-THERE.
>> HANNITY: LAST WEEK BIDEN SAID
THIS IS ALL MUCH ADU ABOUT
NOTHING BECAUSE THE DOCUMENTS
AND THE CORVETTE ARE IN A LOCKED
GARAGE EXCEPT, OF COURSE, WHEN
IT WASN'T LOCKED WHICH SEEMS
LIKE HAPPENED ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
HERE, BY THE WAY, HUNTER BIDEN,
OUT TAKING THE CAR FOR A JOYRIDE
WITH HIS NIECE AND ANOTHER YOUNG
WOMAN WHO IS YET TO BE
IDENTIFIED.
HUNTER CLEARLY HAD ACCESS TO THE
GARAGE, AND EVERY OTHER ROOM IN
THE HOUSE BECAUSE HE LIVED
THERE.
KEEP IN MIND HUNTER'S ENTIRE
CAREER WAS BASED ON SELLING
ACCESS TO HIS FATHER TO SKETCHY
FOREIGN NATIONALS FROM
COUNTRIES, A LOT OF WHOM HATE
OUR GUTS.
SO OBVIOUSLY HUNTER'S PROXIMITY
TO EASY ACCESS TO CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN CONCERNING.
HUNTER IS NOT THE ONLY PERSON
THAT HAD ACCESS TO BIDEN'S
DELAWARE MANSION EVEN THOUGH JOE
SPENDS ALMOST EVERY WEEKEND
THERE CONDUCTING OFFICIAL
BUSINESS, AND WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHO VISITS THE HOME.
THE WHITE HOUSE CLAIMING THERE
IS NO LOG OF ANYBODY THAT COMES
OR ANYBODY THAT GOES.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU THE FACTS.
THAT'S A BLATANT LIE.
THAT'S LIKE, I NEVER TALK TO
HUNTER OR ANYBODY ABOUT THEIR
FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS IN MY
FAMILY.
BASED ON MY INTERVIEWS WITH
MULTIPLE PRESIDENTS OVER THE
YEARS I KNOW FOR A FACT THE
SECRET SERVICE, THEY TRACK EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT ENTERS A
SITTING PRESIDENT'S HOME.
THERE IS DEFINITELY A RECORD OF
WHO HAS BEEN IN THAT HOUSE OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO RELEASE
IT.
THE ENTIRE ORDEAL REEKS OF
CORRUPTION AND FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME, THE RASMUSSEN POLL
IS NOW SHOWING THE MAJORITY OF
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
BELIEVE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
COMMITTED AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE
AND YET THIS COUNTRY IS FACING
MUCH BIGGER PROBLEMS.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT PHILADELPHIA AND
PENNSYLVANIA.
THE FIFTH PLACE OF OUR GREAT
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
THIS IS WHERE THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE WAS SIGNED AND
CONSTITUTION WRITTEN.
NOW PHILADELPHIA IS HELL ON
EARTH.
VIOLENT CRIME, STREET GANGS,
HAVE TURNED VAST AREAS OF THE
CITY INTO A LIVING NIGHTMARE AND
IT ONLY GETTING WORSE.
A DANGEROUS NEW DRUG IS NOW
FLOODING THE MARKET.
ITS NICKNAME IS TRANK AND IT'S A
HORSE SEDATIVE THAT DEALERS ARE
MIXING WITH FENTANYL AND THE
RESULTS ARE GRUESOME.
CAUSING GAPING FESTERING WOUNDS
IN ADDICTS AND LEAVING SOME
UNABLE TO WALK.
THE OVERDOSE DEATHS ARE NEARLY
TRIPLE WHAT THEY WERE JUST A
DECADE AGO AND THAT NUMBER WILL
ALMOST CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO
CLIMB.
SADLY IT'S NOT JUST
PHILADELPHIA.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, OVERDOSE
DEATHS NATIONWIDE ARE
SKYROCKETING.
NOW AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
ANYBODY IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
EQUATE THIS TO THE CHAOS AT THE
BORDER.
THANKS TO THE MASS QUANTITIES OF
CHEAP, LETHAL DRUGS POURING IN
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND A
CULTURE OF LAWLESSNESS AND NO
BAIL LAWS AND DEFUNDING AND
DISMANTLING POLICE DEPARTMENTS
IN ALMOST EVERY MAJOR CITY IN
THE COUNTRY, THEY ARE NOW FACING
A CRISIS, WHAT IS OF EPIC
PROPORTIONS.
DEMOCRATS DON'T SEEM TO NOTICE.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME YOU SAW A
PROMINENT DEMOCRAT WALK THE
STREETS OF WEST BALTIMORE.
MAXINE WATERS DOESN'T EVEN LIVE
IN HER OWN CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES.
WHY?
BECAUSE MAYBE IT'S TOO
DANGEROUS, AND JOE BIDEN, WOULD
HE EVER DARE STEP FOOT IN SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS IN DETROIT,
PHILLY, CHICAGO, AMERICAN
CITIES.
THEY ARE ROTTING RIGHT IN FRONT
OF OUR EYES AND DEMOCRATS, THEY
HAVE THEIR HEADS IN THE SAND,
AND IN MOST CASES, THESE CITIES
HAVE BEEN DRIVEN INTO THE GROUND
BY DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE BEEN
RUNNING THESE CITIES FOR DECADE
AFTER DECADE AFTER DECADE.
YOU HAVE THOUSANDS DYING
NATIONALLY.
MILLIONS HOPELESSLY ADDICTED TO
THESE DRUGS.
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IS NOW
AT RECORD HIGHS.
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT.
THERE IS NO EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS.
THERE IS NO LOCAL LEADERSHIP,
AND YET, THE OH, SO
COMPASSIONATE BLEEDING-HEART
LEFT IS REWARDING THEM BY GIVING
THE DEMOCRATS THEIR VOTE EVERY
SINGLE ELECTION.
PHILADELPHIA HAS NOT HAD A
REPUBLICAN MAYOR SINCE 1948.
I WOULDN